are you looking forward to when the next
character is revealed for injustice too
well that's today as Shazam villain
Black Adam was revealed in the latest
trailer for the DC fighting game I'm
Matt and this is your super-powered
gamespot news update the latest trailer
gives us a look at super girls side of
the story it largely consists of her
clashing with Superman over his
newly-found totalitarian views and it
seems like they're dynamic will be an
interesting one but we also get a quick
look at new playable character Black
Adam we barely see any gameplay of him
but the trailer does show off his super
move which looks pretty awesome we'll
let you know an actual gameplay of him
gets revealed so be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to be the first to see that
injustice two launches on May sixteenth
for ps4 and xbox one another character
that recently got revealed is dr. fate
whose moveset and combos recently got
broken down in another on live stream
you can watch the archive for yourself
on our YouTube channel in addition to a
breakdown of Batman's trusty sidekick
Robin
[Music]
you